na haben sie dienstagabend auch so
gebannt vor der glotze gesessen wie ich
die haut den lukas bei kabel eins geiler
film ja angela merkel konnte den leider
nicht gucken sie saß live bei phoenix
und musste sich rechtfertigen für ihre
russlandpolitik ein am ende darf ich
sagen wenig selbstkritischer auftritt
unter dem motto was hat zwei daumen
runter alles richtig gemacht die mutti
ja wobei manche vorwürfe ja auch
bescheuert sind die ex kanzlerin war
nach kriegsausbruch noch im
italienurlaub und die ist in rente ich
kann ja jetzt nicht für den rest meines
lebens was immer auf der welt passiert
nicht mehr verreisen dürfen und nur noch
in die uckermark gehen
[Applaus]
was hat sie gegen die uckermark
von da kommt man für 9 euro nach sylt
bei ihrem interview comeback sagt merkel
es sei ihr seit jahren bewusst dass
putin zitat die eu zerstören will sagte
aha trotzdem hat sie unsere abhängigkeit
von seinem gas mit nord stream 2 noch
vergrößert und zwar nach der creme
annexion mehr dazu in ihrer demnächst
erscheinenden autobiografie meine
kanzlerschaft leider keil
der ungar ist das uns allen jetzt erst
auffällt wie abhängig wir von
autokratien sind es ist ja so wir
stellen mit billigen rohstoffen aus
russland produkte her und verschicken
die dann hauptsächlich an china unseren
wichtigsten handelspartner
deutschlands handelsvolumen mit china
ist viermal so groß wie das mit russland
darüber müssen wir reden kurz gesagt wir
brauchen dringend ein neues
geschäftsmodell als land denn auf
lieferketten aus china wissen sie kann
man sie nicht mehr verlassen und wandel
durch handel klappt auch nur so mittel
in der uiguren provinz xinjiang zum
beispiel sein mann wurde zu zwölf jahren
verurteilt weil er 15 tage am stück im
fitnessstudio war vorbereitung einer
terroristischen handlungen
das klingt hart andererseits 15 tage
fitnessstudio am stück werden für mich
auch terrorismus meiner mutter
wirklich was für ein abgrundtief böses
regime die uiguren police files
enthüllen zwar wenig neues aber seitdem
gibt es eben gar keine ausreden mehr zum
beispiel für deutsche firmen die in
shenyang fabriken haben und wo zumindest
indirekt von zwangsarbeit profitieren
über eine million menschen muslimischen
glaubens saßen da zeitweise in
umerziehungslager
wir habe ich mir die vorzustellen
sie singen und sind diese bilder
präsentiert die chinesische führung
ausländischen journalisten
kulturen in chinesischem level ja falls
sie darauf eine pointe erwarten müssen
sich selber eine ausdenken es ist
einfach nur schrecklich und wenn
deutsche politiker das schicksal der
uiguren ansprechen dann waren sie das
chinesische außenministerium kritik an
china könne zitat den interessen der
bundesrepublik schaden und das kranke
ist das stimmt sogar ja das stimmt in
einer welt in der 65 prozent 65 prozent
der teile eines deutschen elektromotors
aus china kommen und 54 prozent einer
deutschen windturbine
diversifizieren lautet das gebot der
stunde überfällig nicht zuletzt wegen
der sache mit den kaputten lieferketten
stichwort 0 kowitz strategie in china
ich warte auch noch auf meine wir
brauchen wir brauchen neue
handelspartner immer klar das ist
ziemlich viel transformation auf einmal
für unsere wirtschaft aber sowas hier
darf man echt nicht mehr hinnehmen in
einer video-konferenz mit un
menschenrechtskommissarin bachelet sagte
xi jinping länder müssten ihren
passenden pfad der menschenrechte
erkunden genau und chinas fahrt führt
eben um die menschenrechte herum die
weltmacht china duldet keinen
widerspruch
wer weiß vielleicht hilft uns ja das
geplante eu lieferketten gesetz aus
unserer abhängigkeit europäische firmen
müssen bald missstände in ihren
lieferketten abstellen also sachen wie
zwangsarbeit kinderarbeit ausbeutung
umweltverstöße und die chinesen so bingo
machen wir alles
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck hat
gerade zum ersten mal eine
staatsbürgschaft für ein vw investment
in china verweigert das war ein schock
für die wahrscheinlich auch eine
reaktion auf den notorischen ideenklau
der chinesische staat saugt systematisch
unser know how ab oder in den worten
dieses verlebten gas und auto vertreters
dass die deutsche wirtschaft nicht
einfach nur geschäfte in china machen
will das will sie auch und das soll sie
auch aber sehr wild vor allen dingen
auch in fairer partnerschaft ihr
technologisches wissen hier zur
verfügung stellen voll nett oder
wert unsere geschäftsgeheimnisse
verraten sozialdemokraten
schröder hat als kanzler tatsächlich mal
im wortlaut die chinesische position zu
taiwan übernommen sind halt einfach top
kunden die chinesen deswegen sind ja die
letzten deutschen kanzler regelmäßig zum
klinkenputzen nach china geflogen ist
eine beliebte tradition und längst
eingegangen in die chinesische
mythologie inklusive start puppentheater
und da bewundert dann das publikum
helmut kohl und seine fähigkeit fünf
peking enten zu verspeisen ohne das
massaker auf dem platz des himmlischen
friedens auch nur zu erwähnen gerhard
schröder hat bei einer flasche tsingtao
bier immer gern gesagt mir doch egal was
ihr in hongkong macht hauptsache ihr
kauft weiter den in wolfsburg gebauten
golf bon jovi aber dank haben die wende
angela merkel sagte beim besuch in
peking das wort menschenrechte dann hat
der präsident die zwei panda babys für
den berliner zoo geschenken und alle
haben getanzt wie schön wie schön
wir brauchen ein neues geschäftsmodell
hier bei ihrem phoenix-interview hat
frau merkel übrigens auch erzählt sie
glaubt schon lange nicht mehr an wandel
durch handel mit anderen worten die frau
hat eigentlich alles schon immer richtig
erkannt und dann konsequent falsch
gemacht gut alles ist jetzt übertrieben
aber dass merkel bild der deutschen
verändert sich gerade tatsächlich und
zwar nicht zum guten wir schalten wir
live in den archiv keller unter dem
kanzleramt wo die investigativ
reporterin katjana gerd das ganze ausmaß
des merkel versagen es aufdeckt das kann
man wohl sagen einfach und es ist alles
noch viel schlimmer als wir gedacht
haben hier eben gefunden der als und
quittungen merkel hat mittags nur bei
manchen neben bestellt eine wand an
suppe zweimal hühnchen süßsauer 9
millionen elektromotoren für volkswagen
keine weiteren fragen das ist der weiß
ja wofür jetzt genau der beweis
und falls sie sich noch fragen wer die
bundeswehr kaputt gespart hat das ist
der prototyp des neuen sturmgewehrs das
merke doch persönlich für die truppen
gestellt hat
ich werde noch total paranoid hier
schauen sie mal schauen sie mal das ist
ein angebot der telekom
glasfaserleitung für ganz deutschland
hat sie persönlich durchgestrichen und
darunter geschrieben könnt ihr knicken
wachstums auch brenner
und jetzt hatten sie mal was sind dieser
christlich liegt die gestohlene
goldmünze aus dem bodemuseum das war
nicht der demokraten das war ja katja
kann wirklich sagen viel glück noch für
ihre weiteren recherchen und wir können
ja ich denke hier läuft eine ganz üble
sache ist ihnen aufgefallen wie olaf
schulz regiert beim thema gas immer der
industrie nachgeben politik nie erklären
alles eins zu eins nach dem style immer
meine theorie merkel hat nie aufgehört
scholz ist in wirklichkeit so ein
arbeitsloser schauspieler aus osnabrück
er spielt den kanzler aber sie zieht
weiter die fäden ja prima das ist doch
eine astreine arbeitshypothese guten weg
jetzt sieben müssen mit glauben
[Applaus]
vielleicht hat sie nur
gut
gut auch das gehört zu ihrer bilanz
immerhin hat die kanzlerin ihre cdu
quasi als bestelltes haus zurückgelassen
beziehungsweise
erfolgreich in die opposition geführt
wobei die partei ja gerade erst zwei
landtagswahlen in folge gewonnen hat mit
ihrem neuen chef friedrich merz merkels
alte rivale den sie wir erinnern uns
seinerzeit persönlich entsorgt hat auf
einem wertstoffhof im sauerland aber das
ist längst abgehakt heute hat sie
wirklich nur noch warme worte für den
früheren feind das damals weise
interessante persönlichkeiten sich
aneinander gerieben haben das
[Musik]
rad jetzt noch ein interessanter
fortführung gefunden und
[Applaus]
der cdu alles gute
alles gute fahrt zur hölle eure angela
alles gute
tatsächlich läuft es ja gar nicht so
schlecht unter friedrich merz hat die
ampel beim sondervermögen vor sich her
getrieben und er appelliert erfolgreich
an die konservative seele der union ich
sage nur wehrpflicht beziehungsweise
allgemeine dienstpflicht ja wird als
antrag auf dem cdu parteitag im
september eingebracht ist schon mal eine
frische neue idee oder gut jetzt lösen
18 jährige jungs und mädchen die im weg
rum stehen zwar kein einziges aktuelles
problem der bundeswehr aber hey ich
meine es gibt bestimmt auch gute
argumente für die dienstpflicht ein ja
ob bundeswehr aber nicht nur und das ist
wichtig sondern auch soziale dienste
hilfsorganisation thw
feuerwehrvereine dass sie lernen dass es
soziale kompetenzen gibt dass sie lernen
dass es nicht nur rechte in einem staat
gibt sondern auch pflichten und es würde
unserer gesellschaft richtig gut tun das
würde euch so gut tun die kleinen
rotzlöffel und was haben wir älteren
zuletzt sich alles für euch gemacht oder
glaubt ihr das war einfach die ganzen
schulden zu machen ihr dann später
abbezahlen dürft oder dreimal im jahr
nach malle düsen fürs klima jetzt seid
ihr dran kinder und lindemann hier ist
nicht der einzige der einer wehrpflicht
was abgewinnen kann ihr ausgerechnet
campino frontmann der toten hosen sagte
in einem interview ich persönlich habe
den kriegsdienst 83 verweigert das würde
ich heute unter diesen umständen nicht
mehr tun ach guck mal da meldet sich in
pankow par mit 60 noch freiwillig
stillgestanden für cabrios neuen punk
sampler die toten hosen marschieren ins
manöver mit allen großen wehrdienstes
[Musik]
mai
bruder campinos anklagen der ballade zum
zustand unserer waffensysteme
[Musik]
und natürlich der legendäre party
kracher
da ich denke
der neue deutsche bank jetzt durch und
runterladen nur 699 für
wehrdienstleistende drückeberger zahlen
das doppelte
krank ist wohl wirklich tot
die dienstpflicht könnte eine gespaltene
gesellschaft zusammenführen sagen ihre
befürworter kinder aus unterschiedlichen
sozialen schichten also im grunde
tristan und kevin
könnte man zusammen richtig blöde zeit
haben ja ja und sich vorher gemeinsam
mustern lassen von stabs ärzten die
genau wissen wonach der bund sucht und
wonach nicht auf diese art
werden seelisch geistig artige wie zum
beispiel neurotiker psychopathen und
insbesondere schwachsinnige von der
bundeswehr bald gehen gern gehalten
man achte auf weitgehend ferngehalten
ja ein paar schwachsinn gebrauchte schon
sonst kann es ja nirgendwo
einmarschieren übrigens nicht mal aus
dem pflegebereich kommt applaus für die
idee mit der dienstpflicht so
nachvollziehbar denn wir haben ja gerade
erst festgestellt dass man pflegekräfte
endlich besser bezahlen muss da wären
preiswerte zivis kontraproduktiv und was
soll dabei rauskommen wenn man noch von
der nacht zugedröhnte abiturienten die
verantwortung für medikamente tragen
lässt aus jedem katheder wechsel machen
die heutzutage garantiert tik tok
challenge
kaum machen ein biber auf dem skateboard
mache was sich schon in der pflege sind
amateure viel gefährlicher als verbund
dienst schlicht ja oder nein ulrich von
heesen war früher mal feldwebel und
veranstaltet jetzt in einer
leerstehenden kaserne erlebnis
wochenenden für junge menschen die
wissen wollen wie das damals wirklich
war mit dem wehrdienst und ulrich wie
läuft's ja bombe bombe läuft dass der
max und der serie sind total begeistert
so spannend hatten die sich den
wehrdienst gar nicht vorgestellt die
dachten dass wird hier so eine art call
of duty nicht und jetzt machen die seit
neun stunden ihr bett
darf ich nach hause klar in 15 monaten
wie die oat haben alles schon wieder
vergessen das war der wehrdienst welt
ein meer aus stumpfsinn und langeweile
und zwischendurch wird man von haupt
schulabbrechern zusammengeschossen da
lag dieser ampel wie sie denn dann wird
aus das machst du direkt normal du
grenzt der biene als geburt also
entschuldigung so können sie mit denen
heute aber nicht mehr reden ja ich weiß
ich weiß deswegen gewinnen wir ja auch
kein krieg mehr
ach komm des gut jungs werden eh nichts
mehr höchste zeit für das zweite
frühstück
darf ich auch noch abasolo
klar wenn du willst dass der kamerad und
ich dich ab jetzt nur noch professor
shuji nennen also ulrich bitte man
welche das hier ist eine realistische
simulation den ganzen tag saufen
rassismus und homophobie
sonst war da nichts
warum hat man denn 2011 die wehrpflicht
ausgesetzt weil wir selber nicht mehr
wussten wie wir die sinnvoll
beschäftigen sollen die ganzen pickel
plantagen was gibt es denn zu
bewegungsarten
befindet der stadt ausmachen
einfach mal von links nach rechts gehen
ja gehen einfach nur gehen und aufpassen
dass sie nicht fallen
gm muss man auch lernen
sehr gut machst du dass wir ohne ein
bein nach dem andern wie profi fast
schon überqualifiziert für die gruppe
also wehrpflicht wieder einführen auf so
nen scheiß kommt wirklich nur die cdu so
männer für unsere nächste übung steigern
wir den schwierigkeitsgrad massiv jeder
günstig fliegen nur so viel wir essen
können am anfang machen wir so von ihr
sei bewusst
nur ein exemplar nehmen also da eine
salami nicht natürlich eines oder
armenien
wieviel salami exemplare darf zu essen
marx
denkmal in ruhe drüber nach
und den rest des tages spielen wir eine
schöne runde blitzkrieg das geht so
gerne 1 würfelt trinken jägermeister bei
zwei bis fünf auch so schon mal gucken
h6 da setzt man sich das hier auf und
kippt den jägermeister
ganz langsam ganz langsam von oben in
die gasmaske bis von unten die kurze
hochstein
[Applaus]
hallo und hessen waren und herren china
das kommt so meine damen und herren
die ampel parteien sind übrigens
geschlossen gegen die dienstpflicht sie
haben aktuell allerdings auch ganz
andere sorgen eigene sorgen ihr tank
rabatt läuft überraschend in die falsche
richtung ja die mineralölkonzerne die
konzerne geben laut recherchen der zeit
nur 60 prozent des rabatts an uns kunden
weiter und behalten den rest für sich
wer hätte das für möglich gehalten ach
ja alle
jetzt könnte man sich wieder furchtbar
aufregen über die fdp die uns den murks
vor allem eingebrockt hat oder man
feiert die sache sowie gernot hassknecht
und so trugen die alte fdp ist zurück
mit gernot hassknecht
ist das geil die alten liberalen sind
wieder da lange zeit der wichtigste
medienpartner der heute show vor zwölf
jahren brauchen wir hier genau einen gag
ich musste nur raus kommen und sagen ey
leute fdp und alle so
[Musik]
er war nicht schlecht oder
damals hat die fdp mit dem mövenpick
gesetz ausgerechnet der hotelbranche ein
steuergeschenk gemacht und jetzt
passiert dasselbe mit den
mineralölkonzernen
warum warum schenkt man denen geld in
meiner familie gibt es sogar die legende
mein erstes wort sein auto gewesen
aha das zweite war übrigens
steuersenkungen der steuersenkung und
natürlich es hinten auch gegen die über
gewinn steuer für mineralölkonzerne
obwohl selbst italiener engländer und
griechen einer auf die kette kriegen und
dann wundert er sich über drei vergeigte
landtagswahlen in folge jentner jetzt
aber nicht nachlassen es braucht
unbedingt mehr geschenke die man nicht
kommen sieht wie wär's mit einem
steuerrabatt für wohnung via und
deutsche wohnen die leute lieben wo
novia ohne für den interessenverband
küken schreddern an sie denkt sonst
keiner acht kaum der christen ist im
moment wahrscheinlich auch ausgelastet
mit seinen hochzeitsvorbereitungen im
juli heiratet er ja auf sylt bin mal
gespannt ob bis dahin die ganzen neun
euro ticket banker wieder abgereist sind
und ich war noch nicht auf sollte hatte
so aber ich komme auch nicht wieder
aufnehmen
wären super trauzeuge so und jetzt
brauche ich nur noch einen schluss keck
da fällt mir direkt eine 1 achtung
sdp
alter ich hab so drauf
und wie viele zivilisten
[Musik]
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich